c’était ce fichu chaton encore une fois.
Tout ça, c'est possible
car on a trouvé une façon
de traduire un problème très compliqué
en une tâche que notre cerveau traite naturellement.
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
Eh bien pour les chatons, ça veut dire
fini de se cacher dans des 1 et des zéros.
Pour moi, fini les weekends perdus.
Pour la cybernétique, ça veut dire qu'on a une nouvelle façon assez radicale
de s'attaquer aux problèmes les plus complexes.
Ça veut dire qu'on possède une nouvelle arme
dans l’évolution de la cyber-guerre.
Mais pour nous tous,
ça veut dire que les cyber-ingénieurs
ont la capacité de devenir les premiers intervenants
dans les situations d'urgence.
Quand les secondes comptent,
nous avons déverrouillé les moyens d’arrêter les méchants.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)